it is going to be work that i did with
uh michael desai
mark feldman and dan fisher and that
i'm doing some continuing related work
with where i'm kind of tagging along
with
joanna maisel meredith trotter uh some
other stuff with you avraham
and then a lot of other people have
worked on something
like this including a lot of people in
this room who i'm not mentioning
i'm just going to mention nick because
um people may not know that actually he
has worked on this he may even
deny it at points um
and why why would he deny it because the
uh the the problem
is uh something a little bit a little
bit
uh makes biologists a little bit unhappy
sometimes because it's
the evolution of irreducible complexity
uh
if you have some kind of adaptation that
needs multiple mutations
to do anything um how can how can
evolution
uh ever find this um and then it has
also some some
less loaded names like fitness valley or
fitness plateau that i'll
probably use uh use instead and i'm
gonna say that the you need
k mutations to get it okay so uh why
should we care
um actually so we despite you know kind
of bad reputation we
are pretty sure that this is a real
thing that happens in biology
um you can imagine if you've got like a
signaling protein and a receptor protein
and they need to stick together
and there's a better way that they could
bind but they need to change in concert
all right that should be an example of
this kind of adaptation
the kind of most clear-cut case
is is cancer so the cells in your body
okay they
you can see cancer they can see cancer
as an adaptation on their part at least
in the short term
because they get to take over and uh and
kill you but
okay you don't like that at all so
you've made it
we've evolved to make it very hard for
cells to turn cancerous
um and in particular there are a lot of
genes that will kill them if they start
dividing out of control
and since you have two copies of every
gene you would need to at least
inactivate
a cell would need to at least inactivate
both those copies
uh to turn cancer so that's at least a k
equals two
uh adaptation and then kind of more
generally in this audience you know
we're interested
in you know can evolution get stuck uh
you know
should evolution proceed by single
substitutions or by selection on
interesting combinations and uh
it's it and a couple people been saying
that uh it's
interesting to think about because
there's so many
possible genotypes that are say you know
three mutations
away from your current genotype maybe
one of those is something
really cool that would be we'd be
interested in
okay so but there's two problems with
this uh that make people a little
skeptical about it
the population has to first produce this
combination of different uh mutations
and then it has to uh fix it by which i
mean everyone needs to uh
acquire it in the population so i'm just
going to
work backwards here start with the
second problem
and now we're going to kind of forget
about where this combination of
mutations came from
but to say it's in the population under
what circumstances
can spread starting from some very low
frequency a very low number
okay so the kind of uh classic challenge
that has to overcome
is to avoid being broken up by
recombination the adaptation can't get
split up by recombination so say it's at
some low frequency
is this thing really not not working all
right i'll use my hand
okay so say it's at some low frequency
uh and it's increasing because it has
the selective advantage but it's getting
broken up by recombination
you have a competition between those
effects
you also have recombination feeding in
new copies
from the other uh from the other
mutations that are present in the
population
and then you also have stochastic
effects over there uh
so first thing to notice if
the recombination rate among the
different involved alleles
is smaller than the selective advantage
of this adaptation altogether
well then they don't even need this
influx from recombination
they can just spread they don't even
need to worry about getting broken up
on the other hand if the recombination
rate is much larger
then you need this influx to almost
exactly balance
the loss due to recombination and
selection is just going to be a little
added term
on that of perturbation uh and i i just
wrote this is some some function
of the uh mutant allele frequencies in
the absolute simplest case
it's just the uh the product of uh you
know there's just two mutations
necessary it's just the product of their
two frequencies
uh and so that's that's kind of the
justification for what you you saw in
the last talk
uh where you assume that it's kind of
pinned very the distribution of genotype
frequencies is pinned very close to the
product distribution by recombination
okay so uh what does this mean this kind
of competition between selection versus
recombination
say we have some rare combination given
a one percent advantage
that shows up in some very low numbers
in a population
doesn't need to worry about getting
being broke about being broken up
so one percent selective advantage
corresponds to
recombination rate one percent in
flies or people that's a million bases
on the chromosome
uh infla but the gene densities are
different so it's a hundred genes
in flies uh 10 genes and humans
if it's within that if it's within those
number of genes
then uh it doesn't need to get where it
doesn't need to worry about it otherwise
it does
uh for yeast i don't so for anything
that is not an
obligate sexual organism like
a lot of animals are it's very hard to
measure recombination rates it's not
entirely clear that what we measure
well it is clear that what we measure
when we say we're measuring
recombination is not the relevant
quantity here
but does any i mean does anyone want to
object if i say that
uh yeast they could be we could use
mutations anywhere on the whole genome
probably uh two random genes reassorted
a lower frequency than that
yeah i think that's probably likely
um hiv is actually one of the few
organisms where we do have
some kind of reasonable estimate of the
recombination rate
when it's just evolving within a host
not at a population level
and actually there it is just about one
percent so that only gets one question
mark
because it does seem uh seem more
reasonable to say it's the whole genome
anywhere they can evolve together uh
with bacteria they don't evolve by
crossovers
they evolve by they don't recombine via
crossovers
be combined by shuffling genes you know
taking just one gene or a
small stretch so that means not only
could these
this combination involve genes from
anywhere in the genome it could involve
basically all the genes i mean that's
not realistic because you could never
change all of them at once but given
that you did
they could the whole genome could
basically propagate together
with an advantage of one percent without
being broken up
yeah so it could also be whole genome if
the population was strongly subdivided
or
sexual but selfing for example yeah yeah
yeah so this this is
some other issues that with hiv you
could kind of get into that e coli too
strongly subdivided population so
i was saying with hiv we know the
recombination rate
within a host but you know two people
with hiv
their strains are only very rarely
recombining only when they co-infect
someone else so then
it's a little different but it gets a
bit technical i mean
uh it is something to worry about
because it would still need to spread
within a local region
yeah yeah yeah uh oh and then and then
for cancer it's
definitely whole genome because there is
no recombination there's mitotic
recombination but that doesn't act like
this
shuffling genes acts like mutation okay
so
actually this um this selection for
versus recombination thing is not
a problem for most of the uh most of the
tree of life or you know a lot of
genes and even animals um what is a bit
more
problem is just stochasticity uh
i so of course we already all know all
about branching processes so
i can just say that one percent uh uh
advantage means that if i start with one
copy
of the of the uh one individual who's
got that adaptive combination
there's a 99 percent chance or order
nine you know
there's a very high chance uh
that it's just gonna die stochastically
um and uh and so that means we need you
know
to produce this to get this uh this this
uh
adaptation to fix the population we need
to produce it you know
a hundred times order one over s times
before one of them will be successful
okay so that's that's that's a bigger
problem and that's why the real issue
that's why it's it's
this is a very serious problem how can
the population ever even
find an adaptation that needs a lot of
mutations
all right so yeah i mean the answer is
if you make
if you need a combination of enough
mutations it can never do it right it
can't
it can never find a one particular
combination that where you need to
change every single gene at once in some
complicated way
uh okay but how about for
for for some limited uh level of
complexity
so like i said this is kind of
practically important for a lot of
things we care about
uh and uh yeah the number of potential
genotypes
is growing exponentially with k like i
said so
even being able to do some low k
means that you get to explore way more
genotypes
and potentially find something cool
okay and uh we just want to get some
rough sense of how this question might
depend
on what kind of population we're looking
at because different populations are
going to vary widely
in their ability to uh to find
complexity
okay so just absolute simplest model
because it's gonna get a bit
complicated say that uh you just need
two mutations that need to work together
to get a benefit
when they do come together they give you
an advantage s
either one of them has some small cost
delta could be zero
uh and they each occur at uh at a rate
mu
we have uh just constant population size
big n uh and for now let's say it's
asexual just to
so we don't have to remember one more
parameter
and i'm going to focus for now in the
meantime to uh
to adapt uh which is not
relevant for most kinds of cancer but uh
if you if you
if you want to know about what's
relevant for cancer you can you can ask
me later
and okay so there's a lot of parameters
here so don't hesitate to
to ask me to say again what one is
okay and already it gets really
complicated so this don't try and
understand this here
this is just a picture showing if i vary
just two of the parameters the
population size
and how bad those single mutants are for
you in in
when they're individually present the
different possible kind of
dynamical regimes that can describe
evolution
okay so too complicated let's just
simplify down
even further focus on the fitness
plateau case
where we're going to assume that the
selection against the single mutants is
weak enough so that we don't need to
worry about it too much
uh all right so first guess
let's say we write down the frequency
for the uh
the frequency of doublemints as a
function of time got a nice
uh differential equation there they're
produced by
mutation starting from zero frequency
increased it
uh at r8s and
you can solve it find when uh find when
x2 is of order one
very simple um there's a bit of a
problem here though it doesn't really
depend very much on the mutation rate it
kind of makes you worry
and you know obviously we cheated uh
because we let this selection term kick
in even when
x2 was less than one over n
like when there was you know a tenth of
an individual who had the adaptation in
the population
okay so that doesn't really make sense
uh so
we're going to need to uh this would
only be valid
if there's tons of double mutants
produced in the time it takes
for selection to start increasing them
then
in this case we get a big influx of
mutants then selection acts
and we don't have any worries about
selecting on nothing
uh but if we go to kind of general k
more than two this is a very stringent
condition
uh we need uh the the necessary
population size for this to be accurate
is growing exponentially with k and with
it you know it looks even worse it's
growing
um as the fact is k factorial but
remember we're talking about moderate k
so actually here the constants are more
bigger than this time uh
bigger bigger than s times k oh yeah
yeah the k
the k yeah yeah you you need very strong
mutation your mutation to be the
dominant
force in the population stronger than
selection
and when that's true you can see that
the model is kind of broken
because how are the mutations knowing
where to go
implicitly i've assumed that we can
neglect
all the mutations that aren't leading
anywhere useful actually
when mutation is strong compared to
selection you're getting the whole
population spread out over genotype
space
so the model breaks down there too so
this is this is this is problematic okay
but we got the answer we got we got one
of these uh regimes now the the very big
population case
done okay two more to go uh second guess
all right the problem was that we were
selecting on nothing we need to
we need to take the zero one uh boundary
between the for the for the doubling
seriously
but okay let's make another
approximation
if this is the problem getting that
first double mutant let's say that
that's basically the only problem
all we need to do is is get that first
double mutant and then the first
successful double being right it'll take
you know
one over s of them and then once we do
that we're we're good selection will fix
it quickly
no problem uh okay
so we say all right what's this
frequency of single mutants now no
selection on them so we don't need to
worry about selecting on zero
uh it's just given by by the mutation
rate times time they're coming up in
frequency we're not in a steady state
here we're
we're out of equilibrium uh each one is
produ
it's producing uh double mutants at a
rate mu
can find exactly uh when you get uh one
over s double mutants produced
all right and there we go there we go we
have a new answer for our
uh for our time okay
now it does depend on the mutation rate
that makes
more sense it's a little worrying though
because it only depends on
the mutation rate to the first power
like there was no
need for a double a second mutation at
all
uh and so that's kind of telling you
that one of these mutations
is not rate limiting at all in this case
uh and you know the natural worry is
that maybe we cheated
by ignoring the stochasticity in the
single mutants
you mean the chance that it's going to
die so i i here you know if i if i want
i wrote down a uh a deterministic
expression for the single mutants right
so there's a chance that they die
or maybe that they get lucky right right
this is just the influx due to mutations
maybe they're spreading right so
uh basically what we need is we need
this mean value
to be very big compared to the
fluctuations the stochastic fluctuations
in the number of single mutants
and in particular we need it to be large
at the time where that that successful
double mutant is being produced
uh you know maybe at very early times or
very late times the picture is different
but we don't we don't really care we
just want to get
this one time scale right okay so
uh let's so let's let's check
by treating all the mutants
stochastically singles and doubles
and see if we get a different uh picture
okay so
now the branching process stuff is gonna
gonna really come in handy
here's a picture of a stochastic
realization
of a single mutant lineage start with
one
individual this is a very unusual one
that happened to get lucky
and reproduce lots of times and but
eventually it will go extinct with
probability one
um and i've just left some one over
deltas on here uh to
even though we were ignoring it just to
just to give you some sense that
we shouldn't be hitting uh those kind of
scales otherwise our approximations
break down
and the key remind us what this delta oh
delta is the the the cost of the single
value
right which we're assuming is small
enough and in this picture is going to
just kind of show you what small enough
means
uh so the key thing that we care about
about this stochastic uh lineage here is
the
area under the curve the total number of
progeny of the branching process
because each one of those progeny had a
chance to acquire a mutation become a
double mutant
so the total uh the total probability
success of this lineage conditioned on
this realization
is just the number of double mutants it
produces
times the probability of fixation of
each of those double mutants which we
said before
was s so it's just going to be the area
times the mutation rate times s
all right so we need to know the
statistics for this area the
distribution of this of this area
and all right we know it's a branching
process it's all very simple
in this case it's uh well okay i'm
actually saying it's a near-critical
branching process
uh so that means it's going to die out
but
like we heard uh this morning uh
it's going to take a long time to do
that it takes a long time for the
for the uh the the for the extinction
probability
to approach one uh in particular there's
a
probability one over t that survives
for some t generations and given that it
does
it has ordered the same number
descendants at that time
so just facts about branching processes
they're pretty easy to to derive though
um
okay so t generations length t
height t means area t
squared so put this in
the probability that you have area at
least a is probably that you live
for time root a because then you also
have root a individuals
area a and so the probability that you
get area
at least a goes like 1 over the square
root of a
we have a very long tail distribution
here
only falling off like one over the the
cumulative distribution is only falling
off like one over the square root
what that means is let's say i had some
population
i'm watching it for a long time and what
i really care about in that population
is the total um total number of single
mutants
that have ever existed up to this time
because that's the number
of opportunities to acquire a double
mutant that the population had
what this says is i can just look at the
largest lineage
of single mutants that would be a good
approximation
all those other thousands of lineages
lineages
lineages will contribute
uh a negligible amount to the total
number of single mutants
in other words the most likely path for
a single mutant to be successful is just
the most likely path of population to be
successful is just to have
one enormously lucky single mutant
that persists for a very long time
generates
tons of double mutants enough so that it
easily
uh it easily uh produces 1 over s
and crosses the valley conditional on
the time it survived and you can
straight forward you need the area
to be 1 over mu s so you need the time
to be
root 1 over root mu s this occurs the
probability mu s
get an expression for the total waiting
time and you can see it here this is a
zoomed in picture on an actual uh
simulation uh where we've got blue and
yellow single mutants when they come to
if you get both you have green which is
obviously better
uh and you see uh you get one
big lineage and that's when you uh
that's when you cross the valley and the
the full population size is way off the
screen this is some tiny fraction but
huge absolute number
um yeah exactly so yeah and then this is
just even more zoomed in and you can see
it actually does have the right
uh dimensions that it should okay so
that
now we have uh we filled in all three of
these regimes
and in the process i didn't explain it
to you but we actually found the
boundary
be where you can uh distinguish
where you need to take the stochasticity
of the single mutants
seriously or not and it's actually
whether the
uh there's many single mutants being
produced each generation are not
if n times mu is large the stochastic
and single means doesn't matter if it's
small
it does um and just
one thing i want to say is they got you
know fairly different behaviors and
parameter dependencies
just by varying these population sizes
and
they're kind of like different flavors
of of infinity of the infinite
population sizes
so this one up here the big population
the really big population size
that was effectively infinite we can go
up higher and higher in population size
there's no more interesting regimes
there
this one was in the intermediate was
infinite from the point of view of the
single mutants we could totally ignore
the stochasticity there
but not at all for the double mutants so
it was very important that it was
limited
um and this one down here was
infinite from the point of view of the
single mutants not in the sense that
they were
deterministic they were stochastic but
in the sense that we could use this
branching process approximation
which is actually only valid uh uh when
there's no
uh no competition among the individuals
when the difference is
it was actually a multi-type branching
process but i didn't tell you yeah look
i mean the singular approximation yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah um but even for a single
lineage right technically it's not a
branching process in a finite population
right
uh so right so there's
there's lots of different scales another
question what is museum you want
oh yes this is a leftover slide where i
didn't assume symmetry
between the low side so you have yeah
so that's why you have all these
annoying uh numbers running around
okay so what uh just all together um
what i didn't tell you about were kind
of the bad regimes where
it was uh hard to adapt so basically you
want to live
in this area that we talked about to how
to be able to find a complex adaptation
easily
so that means you want at least a
medium-sized population
not too small i didn't say but if you
live down here you're in that problem we
talked about before
where you have to worry about wandering
off in sequence space and going to the
wrong place
not diffusing over populations over
sequence space now but
the whole population wanders um
and you need the uh the single mutants
not to be too bad
um just once maybe for people
who come from population genetics
background the one surprising thing
about this condition that the single
mutants not be too bad is that normally
we measure the selective coefficients
relative to the inverse population size
relative to the strength of drift that's
not what we have here
uh it's relative to something that
depends on the mutation rates and the
selective coefficient
of the complex adaptation and actually
we can allow more we can allow a bigger
cost of the single mutants as we
increase the population size
even though they're being selected
against more efficiently so
you want you want to be careful with
your intuition here that's because you
go
you get more often exactly exactly
exactly
lower frequencies but more absolute
number and in this case
absolute number is all that matters
okay so uh yeah what what are some
numbers here
uh i i i'm uh
i don't want to take these too seriously
but let's say
we had two exact
um uh uh nucleotides that we wanted to
change
point mutations and if we change them
both we get a one percent
advantage okay well then we have a
condition
on uh on the population size and the
cost
population size seems to be big enough
cost needs to be
small enough so that we can see them um
if we put in the mutation rate for e
coli
we get a million uh
that looks tiny compared to like the
number that are
living in your gut but i want to be
careful i mean because this is
this is also a time scale and a million
generations of e coli
is a pretty long time but if you if you
uh if you use the full population size
it's it's less of a problem
um rna virus with a much higher mutation
rate
get a much lower uh uh
requirement on on the population size
something that's tiny for a virus
uh should easily find the all the the
dopamine mutations that are that are
beneficial no problem
okay so that was all asexual let's put
let's make some sex
uh i'm not going to go through this in
detail um
just here's another one of these uh
parameter
uh slices uh where now i'm looking
we're looking at uh how the depth of the
valley so how bad the single mutants are
the strength of recombination more
recombination this way how how frequent
sex is
and then how long it takes the
population to adapt as a function of
that
uh and then the height of this is just
how long it takes in absolute terms and
i've colored it
according to whether sex is helping or
hurting the population
so two things kind of jump out at you
there's this really
horrible mountain here where you can't
adapt at all
that's uh that's where you're getting
stuck because the
mutations are individually bad and
they're always recombined so you're kept
close to the product distribution and
every time
you get a double mutant it's split up
and the constituent single beans are
selected out
and here actually the pop the times
across the valley
is growing exponentially with population
size so basically
evolution is not going to cross this way
if it if it wants to cross that thought
it's going to find
some trick to do it and then the other
main feature is uh
we get this nice uh uh division right
where we thought it should be
uh where where the recombination rate
and the selected coefficient roughly
match
when recombination rate is higher than
that
it tends over a lot of parameter space
to break up those double mutants and
hurt you
and when it's uh when it's lower than
that it doesn't really break them up
very much
so all it can do is help you by bringing
together
uh single mutants that were that were in
the population it's it's a little bit
more complicated that that's not
an absolutely perfect pattern but you
can see it's it's pretty roughly true
okay so you can just put this all
together and here's just a couple
different parameter slices plot together
to show
that we can change the parameters a bit
and you get very different
dynamics or even times across the valley
so we've got
how long it takes to adapt over there as
a function of population size for
actually fairly small population sizes
um for a a
mutation that provides a five percent
advantage and just the
you see this big split where
for a recombination rate that's on the
order of s but a little smaller
it gets very very easy to adapt as the
population gets big
for recombination rate so order of
magnitude bigger
it becomes impossible i know the the
points are simulations the
curves are analysis uh and you know you
could bring this
you could really bring these even these
two economist rates even closer
to the uh to the selective advantage and
you would still see
this huge jump at large populations so
we get totally different dynamics
just depending on some some fairly minor
quantitative changes in the in the
recombination rate
and also then as we get very different
dynamics as a function of population
size
okay so what does all mean uh just again
the adaptations can spread no problem
without any help from intermediate
genotypes that can be as bad as you want
or
as absent as you want as long as the
advantage
of the of the combination is bigger than
the recombination rate among its
constituent mutations
and you don't need a very big advantage
for for most
organisms you can get some
limited amount of complex adaptation
very easily as long as the population is
large
the intermediate genotypes are not too
deleterious and
uh you it it really helps actually if
you have a little bit of recombination
not too much
and we you know we can make all these
statements quantitative
uh and when you put in real numbers for
them
uh there's no no obvious reason at this
at this level
why you shouldn't have complex
adaptation uh all the time
actually so the stuff i'm doing well i'm
tagging along with joanna on right now
it's very easy to write down a model
where actually most adaptation
is complex if you have a diverse
population and the diversity
uh doesn't hurt you too much um okay but
so what we need to do here
um actually for some reason i never
uh really calculated the valley crossing
times in detail
for arbitrary complexity and
recombination rates
i i just started to do it during the
break because i felt bad about that
and it looks like uh you can get uh
it it looks like it's basically
intuitive if mutations are very hard to
come by if the mutation rate is really
low
then you don't want to have uh then sex
is really bad because
uh you know you you you're
the breaking up the combination
dominates when mutations are fairly
frequent
uh then it's really an issue of
combining them and then
and then and then sex uh seems to help
but i mean i just you know
need to look at that in more detail um
really to make this more a more
realistic model
we need to take the rest of the genome
seriously right now i've totally ignored
it i've assumed it's all static
or you know not doing anything
interesting that interferes with the
adaptation
and really in most of these real
populations um
there should be all kinds of selection
going on in the rest of the genome
um and there can be all kinds uh of
hitchhiking
of these uh individual uh constituent
mutations
on adaptation that's going else from the
genome there can be interference so we
need to know
uh how that should actually work but and
the most
the most glaring uh problem right here
is that there's no
actual uh real fitness landscape in here
i'm just assuming one
no actual data so really the most
important thing would be
would be to actually take some natural
population maybe
cancer where we could hope to have some
idea
of what the actual fitness landscape
looks like um
and actually see some evolution in
action and uh
and see if this is this theory is
helping us uh understand it at all
thank you
nick you're gonna you test
no so it's very neat we're putting
together a theory but how do we know
what's happening
could you test it by looking for amino
acid substitutions that have come about
by two or even three codon changes
rather than once
so the idea is it goes through a
deleterious where
yeah i mean just the the hard part there
is knowing that
it really was deleterious in the middle
that whether where yeah got stem loop
structures
and that have had compensatory evolution
at both sides i mean that one's got to
be an example
it's it will i mean there's a problem
you need to convince people that it's
not just purely compensatory okay so
the example here is it's one of these
things or two it's pretty adaptive but
it's
just minimum compensatory well the night
i really hear the dynamics really it was
crucially important
that uh in this case where the two the
two
um genes needed it was just two genes
that needed to work together they needed
to fit together
that when they both changed the new
combination was actually better
if it's not if it's just the same it's
it's you get a different picture
actually
yeah yeah uh so it's it's yeah it's you
get a really clear valley there
in the data but it's hard to say okay
this is really
an adaptive change
okay thank